for any world leader it is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity with the
Queen as your host there's nothing quite
like a British state visits
only two other American presidents have
had the honor and now is the turn of
Donald Trump like other American
presidents Donald Trump isn't getting
that carriage procession down the mouth
and that's mainly because of security
but by the time he reaches Buckingham
Palace he will witness that full
spectacular display of British pageantry
for the ceremonial welcome and this is
much bigger than that cup of tea with
the Queen last year a state visit is the
ultimate diplomatic gift from the UK
government the glamorous state banquet
is always a show-stopping moment and
Trump wouldn't be the first to be
overwhelmed by it President Obama
accidentally started speaking over the
national anthem but that's ok when
you're among friends and the Royals are
seen as vital for reinforcing this
longstanding friendship
it gives special flavour to this
especially you know the United States is
relatively a new country here in the
United Kingdom with all the symbolism
and the tradition the royal family
symbolizes I think it's special it's
makes it more colorful and the flavour
is more interesting especially for the
American audience it will be a family
affair with the president bringing as
many relatives as possible to meet the
Windsors and the 93 year old monarch
supported by her children and
grandchildren
one absentee will be the Dutchess of
Sussex who has the excuse of maternity
leave for not meeting her fellow
American who she once described as a
misogynist but the Prince of Wales whose
views on climate change could not be
more different from Donald Trump will
play a significant role in making the
president feel welcome one of his
advisers on environmental issues
believes that Charles could in fact see
it as an opportunity and not add sure
hopefully as he has done before he can
share some of his passion share some of
his expertise share many of his positive
messages including with people like
President Trump who don't think climate
change as a serious issue to hopefully
build some kind of common cause into the
future over the past 67 years the Queen
has developed genuine friendships with
other presidents suggestions that
Trump's latest visit would embarrass her
just won't be a consideration she has
played her part in this diplomatic dance
many times before Rhiannon Mills sky
news at Buckingham Palace